I thought I'd check in with my good
friend Deon Cole and see how he's doing
Deon thanks garnet these have been some
trying times were in and over the past
couple weeks thousands of people have
taken to the streets to protest hundreds
of years of racism and I must say I was
very shocked by the amount of white
people that were out of there and not
only that some of the signs they were
hold and they were they were truly
powerful like this one white silence
equals white consent I love that
powerful there's another being black is
not a crime thank you to that white
person for spreading that word I really
appreciate you and some of the signs I
saw white protesters holding they uh
they missed the mark not helpful at all
like this one the darker the chocolate
the healthier it is true but that is not
why anyone is marching please know that
also saw white person holding this sign
how do not hate the idea of ages Elba
being the next James Bond no one hates
that idea you just waste the design and
you waste good sharpie good Sharpie ink
wasted on that here's another I drafted
a black quarterback in fantasy football
good for you I hope it was Colin
Kaepernick now here's another sign I saw
Africa is Toto's best song debatable
have you heard of Rosana hmm it's a jam
I promise you and finally this one is
from really got to bring back
what's happening okay I'll give you that
that was a great show and while we had
it we might as well bring back the fresh
prince with Deon Cole back to you come